I'm gonna try to join Wade's game here. Oh
My god, I just went in on my life. Oh
Boy, howdy. Oh
Hi
Alright, okay, I got where are you guys?
White like grayscale when I'm like inside
Boy
me like
Ripoff Bennett foggy vibes. Oh ho this is such a ripoff of Bennett body. All right, I can already tell him and I hate this
Well, you made progress. I'm not making progress. I wish I could get back down to you guys
I can't get back over the banana. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
okay, so we do a full flip in the air without touching anything you get a bigger boost on the jump Oh
zing
Things that we had to learn slowly over time. Oh that helps
Okay. Yeah, you can't touch anything, okay
Why do you always
This next section sucks. Hmm. Okay, guys, did we win? Oh my god
How do you oh?
There's a banana in the air Oh pick it up on the top and Anna and then boost off of it. I think Frick
Oh my god, Wade. This is the worst
It's funny
Okay
Why are there levels you might level up your character or something?
I'm not good at this but I like this and you know, I kind of liked Bennet foggy at first too
but I feel like I
Just found so far away. Oh wait. Oh
Man oh god. Oh god, I just
And a half that we're at right now mark wait, where are we supposed to go
We're supposed to go up. I want to see it so bad
I just I can't do I
Can't do floaty controls guys. I just can't I did it. That's great
No, oh my god screw this noise
Nonsense, wait did I just can't do floaty controls? I need my controls to be nice and precise and fordable floating
Floating. Oh my god. I'm gonna die all backwards. That's the way
There's a reason I stopped playing
rage games is because I have a visceral reaction to like controls that I don't like I just
Will not relax he'll get I will be good at this because getting good at
You're only saying that cuz you know, it'll make me matter I'm back up here I
Didn't take two hours like last time I didn't see shit wait you didn't I?
Got a pause for a second. I'm just oh
Yes, hey, thank you, thank you perfect chick-fil-a time. Thank you
Lunch, I got some chick-fil-a. Oh just take a little breather in
30 seconds. I
Don't care what Wade is accomplishing I have what I need right here
So I just got this as far as I got in two hours. I just reached
Get further up there becomes wind. Oh, no, what mark what take you back? I love this game
It's fine everything's fine
No, no, no, I'm not cheating. I'm just you paused. Yeah, I'm reading the controls
Okay
You're fakie, why does your finger hurt? What are you talking about?
button too hard because he's
Oh, you're playing on controller. Yeah. Yeah. It's a controller is easier. Ah
God, damn it. It's oh, hey, well, I'm starting to get a feel of it
What did I just get the worst is when you bounce up somewhere and then you know, you're sick lands on it and yeah I
Swear I was getting bigger boost jumps before oh
My god the Flies, why do the Flies exist that's the water mmm wait, I'm so glad you're having fun up there
Oh
There's a bit
Okay
So you got to hold it down like all the way you mean you have to hold it down like all the way
You don't have to let go of it is what I'm saying
Oh, it's so much better. If you just hold down space the whole time. It's so much better. It's like infinitely better
Chill kid chill, who's what who's kid me? I
Don't work concerning me I don't know my boots seem to be working good
Oh my god, that was like the superest boost ever jump so high oh my god, I can't I can't with this I
literally I can't
It makes no sense the inconsistency of the power. Yeah, the power seems crazy to me I don't I'm not Auto percent sure
What the deal is with the power flip jumpy. Oh my god
The whole the whole wall jumping concept, but see oh my god, it's okay
Mark, it's fine. Oh
Fuck. Yes
Wait, I didn't do it. I have a fuckup I'm angry sad because I wanted to succeed
I know I I thought I was done. I fucked up. I think I could have made it if I understood what was happening
I
Do feel like I'm getting better though, like this feels like it might actually be
What someone just came tumbling down by me? All right. So leave is this game hackable. Are we about to get fucking hackers in here?
Well, there's there's somebody fuck. All right. Oh, yeah
Oh my god, oh my god
Oh
My god, stop jumping off of the walls. Oh my god
You can't stop jumping
Interesting. I just I need them. I need a moment. You need a moment. Hi, you need a moment
I've got nice nice sandwiches that are just going nice and cold
Well, I'm trying to oh my god. Stop jumping up the wall. I'm
So happy that it's not me down there for once it's just if it would
Stay it do why is it with JP? We're in a better place. Why does it do that?
Oh, is it because I'm holding down space? Oh, that makes sense
No, no god. Oh
My god, I swear I swear - I swear - fuck I swear to fuck just be
Played this oh, oh, oh my god. Oh, it's so hard to just get it in to where I need it to be there
We go. Yes, okay. I'm here. I'm gonna stop. Okay, here we go. And oh
Stop stop moving. Oh my god. Why did I did the biggest super jump I've ever done in my existence
Oh my god. Okay. I know how to do this. I know
Okay, everything's fine
Here's the hill with the window yes. Oh my god, okay
My friend is here no wait, how's it going? Where's mark? I got min. I'm coming. I
Fucking Oh Laxus game you guys like this game. I love this game. Hey, dr. Pope is over here. Whoever the fuck that is
I don't know. Dr. Pope. I almost dr. Pepper day. I heard that name though
Fucking fuck go away. Hey Marco
You sound different why would I sound different so same old me
Know what mark? I feel your pain, you know, dude don't my pain. Oh fuck
If you can't say that with the mouthful of chick-fil-a, I just I'm getting better is the thing I'm getting better at it
Yeah, I mean I spent literally two hours we recorded for over two hours. You really don't get past this
Where where did you get to I guess where you just saw pee
Really? Yes, isn't that hard? I?
I found the heck. I'm a hacker. I'm the best. Okay, I found the way I'm gonna get up this mountain
through unbelievable pro skills
Okay, that's really difficult to do I'm not gonna try to do that when I can't even do the basic way are there more flies
Hears birds. No, I mean I'm saying are there more flies here where I am, it feels like there's more
Okay, here we go
Do your clothes and stuff
You know what my controller's dying go fuck yes, I'm switching a mouse and keyboard. Oh you both on controller get in the hole. Oh
I'm in a new area. I've never been here before. Yes. Yes. Yes guys guys guys guys
Did what everyone else did thank you
Fuck fuck I got it. Oh come on. The slipping is really unnecessary
It's such a narrow angle that you have to set goddamnit oh
Not oh
No
Okay. No, why would you grab there Oh
Bob I might kill
My own I might kill Oh mark calm down. Everything's fine. It's working. Fuck you found your secret mantra
Fuck calm down. It's working. Everything's fine
It's really difficult up here as well. Let you know. Where are you and why don't I care?
Good, it's fine. This is uncharted territory for me
What Bob Bob shut up don't use me for your monster you're stealing my skill
Hey everything I keep slapping my
Stupid round body where it doesn't deserve to be so not like it. Oh, oh
Oh
Oh, I knew that was a dumb
Sombrero
Sombrero guys, that's great. Yeah. Yeah, that's cool. So proud of you. Oh, it's the wind there's wind
Wind
There's clearly wind up here, please pull go to the right please God
It's fine, it's fine. It's fine. No God, why would you do that?
That makes no sense
Oh, no, no, no. No, no, don't be like Mark. Don't be what are you talking about? What are people saying about me, huh?
I'm not no one's saying anything
Yeah, no no mark down like mark and shut your trap I swear
I swear I don't care what you think of me. Just it better be yes. Yes. Yes
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make wiser winks. Why is there some wind?
I'm not gonna make it
You fool. I feel like the wind is inconsistent
I just want to say that straight up you have to jump it like a really sharp angle to like avoid the wind
Wait, I just realized I didn't want your advice I concur I'm offended that you thought I needed your help
Who's in the same place is me you so how does that feel? This is not me. Wow
You're into the top mark I've seen the golden the promised land you have not you have not you have not
No one no one has I I have it's golden. No one has no one has
No one
No one has it all I can't get I can't get these people and why aren't they you too? I can't
get a steep angle cuz my
stupid round body hits the thing and therefore I don't get I
Can't I can't do it's impossible to do a steep angle. It just is
Oh
My oh my god, oh my god, it's just it's definitely not impossible. Ok, so just it is so
Unbelievably impossible. Oh my god, really? Oh,
Well, you're keeping it together mark
If I be quiet, I feel the path
If I am loud the path eludes me
Well, I think I see the path feel to you
That also is true. Oh my gotten out there. I go fucking every god I'm oh
Man what have I done mark you see where I am. No, I don't Oh God Oh careful, Baha Oh
God okay. Oh
No, I was the hair bob once I reached my apex kill yo, fuck me you're gonna see
gameplay
Gameplay the likes of which you've never seen
Yes, yes, yes, what is this what this is not the top the top
What no no, no not like this now like this ho boy here we go
Power blast like that. I'm better than you. I think maybe yours is just uh,
Okay. I'm at the boost effect of hearts. You've got the explosion. That's why it's all the same unit
Here we go. Visit. I'm up out of here. Oh, fuck me. Well, it's good to see you dude. Hey, bud. How you been?
Nope. Oh god. No, no not like this. I am so close. Oh
It's not falling over you little you little bitch you okay? Why are you kidding me? No. Oh
My god
Hating everything about this entire game
Yes, yes, yes, okay, I'm here my skill is too many people here. Oh my god. Oh my god
There goes my momentum
No, I'm not where's the top I don't know
But not that bad here we go back to a controller the controller is so much better
No, I'm making the keyboard work for me. You know what I mean?
Just take a break
Hey, I hate this so much guys I can't describe my hate for this I've got a controller I'm ready
Did you both get out of here while I was fucking around? No, yeah. Oh, wait what? All right. I'm not back down
So I'm I'm the best if I could stop I mean I know why it's happening
But I refuse to let go of the spacebar because of principles that I have sure sure
Yeah, I have principles unlike a certain
Freshly shaven, man. I
Will not let go of the spacebar. I just won't
Don't you're not boss now if you're still down there. Oh stop
Are you on top right now? Fucking try not to lose it? Yes, I am. But also I'm trying to progress because I'm skilled
I it's not just a constant fight to not lose. It's a constant fight for victory. Here we go
In it to win it
Is the wrong way to go Oh God, okay. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my oh my. Oh my I
Swear I swear there we go. I'm up. Oh
My god, well, I'm back down again. Well, I'm up. Oh my god, I forgot that you get super Oh God